adorned with flags from both countries
the first cargo trucks crossed the
border between Colombia and Venezuela
after years of political conflict
the symbolic moment as delegations from
both governments met in the middle of
the Simon believer Bridge Colombia's new
left-wing president Gustavo Petro had
made the reopening of the Border a key
campaign promise
I think today is a historic day for the
region for the country for South America
globalization is first and foremost a
relationship between neighbors anyone
who measures the flows of trade cultural
exchange and population movement will
always find that the greatest amount is
between neighbors that is how it was
here before sectarian Madness took over
hearts and brains
the first trucks Crossing from Colombia
were loaded with toilet paper plastic
and medical supplies the one from
Venezuela with rolls of aluminum
registration believes that trade between
the two countries will reach a billion
US Dollars by the end of the year and
possibly 4 billion US Dollars by the end
of his administration four years from
now and they hope that most will benefit
the millions of people that live along
the border
hopefully this will help with the
shortages in Venezuela and reduce
Contraband and the extortions we were
subjected to to cross I think it will
make life easier
relations between the two countries had
reached Rock Bottom in 2019 when former
Colombian president Ivan dukespierre had
their efforts to force regime change in
Venezuela
the shutdown worsened security along the
border emboldening crime ganks that
control smuggling and drug trafficking
local entrepreneurs say the Border
should never have been shut
it's been seven years without vehicles
passing through here greatly affecting
the cultural social and economic reality
of the region millions of people had to
learn dangerous Crossing ending up
victims of violence and disappearing but
what's coming is a different border that
will hopefully generate employment for
all but while the reopening is a welcome
First Step everybody here agrees much
more needs to be done to overcome the
economic security and humanitarian
crisis affecting this border region
Alessandra Al Jazeera cucuta